So I have here, this is a butterfly cold, a morpho butterfly.
And I want to tell you what this butterfly,
my nail Polish and soap bubbles have to do with one another.
Um, and so I'm going to talk to you about the optics of structure, Pearl color.
So normal colors are based on pigments,
where you have some colors of light that get absorbed in some that got
reflected. Some things, this particular butterfly, for example,
use geometry as a way to generate color.
Let's start with us soap bubbles. So when you're looking at a soap bubble,
it sort of looks all shimmery and rainbow. And as you let it sit there,
even if you're not doing anything to it,
the colors change and they go through different rainbow colors.
So soap films are made out of something called surfactants.
So the reason soap works is,
but you've got oils on your skin and you want to wash them away with water.
So you have to have a molecule that has some, um,
oil favoring portion and some water favoring portion,
and they have to be stuck together. So these are things that are like liquids.
So when a soap film, I've got little molecules,
these little head dots, they like water. These inside parts are fatty tail,
and then they assemble into layers like this.
And then I'm going to end up with water up here, water in here,
water down here.
So it turns out that this structure is enough to get all of those interesting
colors out. So let's sort of break this down. So imagine I have,
I have a bunch of wares like this,
and they are some distance D apart.
I'm going to send in some wave of light.
So it comes in and some of it gets reflected.
So it says angle data. And then this is also angle theta.
So things get reflected by the same angle.
Some of it's going to keep on passing through,
and this again is angle feta.
And then it's going to bounce out at angle theta and come back out
here.
So now I've got two waves of white that have traveled in different distance.
And for us to be able to see them,
we need them to make sure that they're both in the same phase.
So if I had two waves of light,
let's say like this and one like this, and I want to add them together.
This one, I got nothing.
So the peak up here cancels with the trough down here, and I got nothing.
So for me to see anything,
they both need to have peaks in the same place
and troughs in the same place.
And everything we're going to look at is the distance between neighboring
peaks. And this is the wavelength and we're going to call it Lambda.
So we want to add these two together to get a more
intense signal. Okay?
So what we'll do get out of this is a condition on the white,
so that we see a certain wavelength and that's going to be a function of the
distance and the angle. So we're going to work this out.
So now let me label some points on here.
Let's see the wave travels in like this,
where it intersects the first one I'm going to call this point.
A point B is going to be the second place
it intersects. And then point C is going to be the reflected,
the first reflected bounce.
And then I'm going to draw a right angled line up here.
So this is a right angle with this,
and it's going to intersect this original beam at point
D.
Now what we're going to do is we want a condition that the light is going to
have traveled in here,
bounced off and goes from a to D and then the light down here,
it's going to have traveled from a to B to C.
And we want to make sure that it's in phase at the same point and gets to Dean.
And at the same point, it gets to see that's going to give us a condition.
And that condition is that the distance it travels on the bottom.
So that's going to be length AB plus the length
VC is going to be some multiple of
an Lambda plus the distance from a to D.
So we're going to do this using a little bit of trig.
So I'm going to write down the right triangle here,
and then that'll be everything we need to know. So this is my right angle,
and this is angle feta. It has a high pot nous.
H what I know is that this bottom leg here is going to
be H times co-sign feta.
And the vertical line here is going to be each time sine theta using this
triangle. We're going to work out exactly what these distances are.
So our first triangle we're going to look at is a B,
and then the right triangle that's down here.
So I know that this vertical distance is length D that's the
distance between my layers of soap.
So what I know is that the length D is equal
to the length a B times sign of data.
So that's one condition that tells us that length AB is equal
to D divided by sine of data. Okay?
So now we need to figure out what the length from a to D
is. And so we've got another right triangle here.
So now I know that the length from a to C is the hypotenuse of
this triangle. So that tells me the length,
a D is equal to the length a C
times in this case,
this is going to be co-sign of the angle.
So this is co-sign feta. So now let's work out what AC is.
So we almost have this,
we can go back to this triangle that we started with here.
What we know is that half the length from a to C is the
length from this intersection to B.
And so we can use our right triangle again to solve this.
So we know that the length a B is the high pot news.
So half of the length from a to C is going to
be a B times co-sign of the angle theta. Okay,
so now let's put this together.
So we got a D is equal to two,
a B co-sign theta squared.
So now we know what this distance is,
and we know that AB and BC are the same distance.
So this gives us a way of relating, uh,
the distance di to the angle of incoming light
and the wavelength of the light and the wavelength of the light is what gives us
that color. I guess I should write out the final equation. Two D times,
sine theta is equal to N times Lambda.
So Lambda is the wavelength of light,
and that determines the color D is the thickness of layers.
And feta is the incoming light. The soap films are filled with water,
and the water is constantly draining out of it. And so that's,
the layers are getting closer and closer and closer together.
And what you're seeing is that as the layer thicknesses change,
you're going through this whole rainbow spectrum of colors.
So why don't we see this in everything to make these layers,
this kind of size, it's pretty special.
So wavelengths of light are in the hundreds of nanometers.
The periodicity in a crystal is in 0.1 nanometers.
That's a thousand times different from each other.
So how is biology going to get something with a really regular
patterning like this?
And it turns out that what biology does is it turns to these things called
minimal surfaces. So this is the ideal shape of a soap film.
If you stretch it across some boundaries.
So this is something that's really easy for nature to make,
because cell membranes are basically just fancy soap films. Um,
so it can use this idea to pattern a structures that are a
specific wavelength.
And it turns up with the structure that's used in the morpho butterfly that
sitting right here is something that's called a gyroid.
And I've got a model of a gyroid in my bag to show you.
It's got yarn stuck to it.
So this is a 3d printed model of a jar, right? So this is really,
really intricate surface,
but it's really something that's quite easy to make just from soap membranes.
And this is the structure.
It can set the periodicity of the layers here to the right kind
of blue that you're seeing in that butterfly.
So what's the butterfly making gyros out of, cause it hasn't got soap in it.
I mean really far on a butterfly wing, you get wing scales,
these little pillars that have shapes in them.
And if you zoom inside those, each one of those was once a cell.
So it had a living cell membrane.
So the cell membrane takes the shape and then infills
half of it with a protein called chitin. And then after the several dies,
the cell membrane gets stripped away.
But what you're left with is a protein that has this template into it,
and that's, what's giving it this color. And it's really this complicated,
beautiful surface that's giving this really
striking blue to this butterfly.
Do that diagram again for the butterfly,
all the numbers would work out to give us the wave length of.
Yeah. And so one thing that you might notice is that in the soap film,
you really saw a lot of rainbows and this it's pretty similar
color when I tilted around.
So you'll notice that it gets a little bit more or less intense,
but the color itself doesn't change.
And that's something we didn't see with a soap film.
So the soap film that angle really matters.
And so something about using this kind of structure is it has
repeated angular structure, but when you come in at different angles,
it behaves a little bit like it's all layers and all the same direction.
And what's happening with your nail Polish.
Yeah. So my nail Polish is something that's called a diffraction grading.
So it's not quite the same thing. It turns out it's a polypropylene,
it's a polymer, that's doing all of this,
but it's effectively a film that has a bunch of, um,
a bunch of repeated layers in it.
And instead of it being layers this way,
there are layers this way and that's reflecting light off differently in
different angles. And it's exactly the same optics that's going on.
Were you impressed that I had one of those butterflies ready for you?
Absolutely. That was fantastic.
We didn't even play on that. I just had that on the wall.
Yeah. And it's exactly the right butterfly. It's beautiful. Butterfly.
Just think when that butterfly came to it's an unexpected demise.
It didn't know it was going to be in a number four video.
Yeah. Well now it's famous.
It doesn't do it much. Good though. Does it.
Poor butterfly? It's beautiful.
Well, this man doesn't know about moths and butterflies, isn't worth knowing.
And the collection they have here is extraordinary.
We couldn't possibly look at them all, but let's look at Sam.